the world is it's cruel like my dad
always told me he said this world will
chew you up and spit you while in net
his honest-to-god truth around 600,000
people are homeless on any given day in
the US many assume that those on the
streets have made the wrong choices in
life or simply aren't trying hard enough
I spent time with two women who have
been homeless for years to find out more
about why it's so hard to get out of the
cycle what are we sitting on here this
is the bed what's underneath these
blankets pallets wooden pallets and then
cardboard it's not supersoft
no how did you guys come together to be
in this relationship
we were both homeless at the time and I
was going through a crystal meth
addiction machine going through an
abusive relationship saw saved her from
her abusive relationship like she saved
me from drugs wanting to find out more
about the challenges that homeless
people face
I spoke with Laura Guzman the director
of a nearby homeless Resource Center one
of the most common denominators is
people with histories of trauma among
women about 75 to 100 percent in many
jurisdictions women where homeless have
been impacted by child sexual abuse so
sometimes is trauma the reason but often
times is the inability to pay rent
making a little money nationally there
are only 34 affordable units for every
100 extremely low-income renters so it's
not surprising that many people struggle
to pay rent even with an income but when
you're on the streets finding and
keeping a job becomes even more
challenging challenges that we have
lack of sleep no address transportation
getting to those different jobs without
getting a ticket not having a working
phone when you're homeless is a 24-hour
job yeah
to walk to try to get a meal you have to
wait for the showers sometimes Oh
morning you know if you're sleeping on
the streets that you haven't been
hassled and you're ten has now been
destroyed when people have this vision
that people don't work actually they're
working all day long what happened with
your last cooking job I quit
one of them because we were moved around
numerous times by a Department of Public
Works and the cops go in there sweeps
like why quit a job if it's all you got
it's all we have is a tent and that's
some place to call home
so you see there go to work or protect
your place to stay a couple of days
later I stopped by Linda and Chanel's
tent
shanell was sitting outside sick with
what she thought was food poisoning
she guys are in the tent last night
Chanel's throwing up like crazy what
what's that like living on the street
being being sick like that it's really
hard because you don't have everything
that's needed to really take care of the
person you're with or yourself for that
bet for people living on the streets
transitioning from homelessness can seem
like an almost impossible task but that
doesn't stop people from trying I want
better things for myself
but being in my predicament and what I
used to do put me here and once you're
here it's like you've done a 50 feet
home and you're trying to climb out and
every time you get gang near to the top
you slip and you're back down at the
bottom